so I'm gonna be honest with you guys I
was going into this movie and I was like
there's no way I'm gonna like this movie
it's going to be a piece of [ __ ] I'm
gonna rip it apart I just know it and I
walked out of the movie actually
thinking to myself bear with me I was
right and that's why you never doubt
yourself
the Smurfs - so the Smurfs 2 is the
sequel to The Smurfs which I never did a
video on because I was like you know
what I'm taking one back for myself not
gonna watch the first Smurfs movie so I
never saw the Smurfs 1 however I never
got the feeling even after watching this
movie that if you haven't seen the first
Smurfs movie this experience is gonna be
completely ruined for you you know what
you need to know and in The Smurfs 2 you
have the Smurfs and they're in Smurfs
land Gargamel's in our world he's a
magician because everyone's like oh he
turns people into frogs she's a great
illusionist so he gets a lot of money to
play these big gigs but he still wants
to wipe out all the Smurfs and take over
the world and Gargamel has is like bad
devious Smurfs he calls him Nadia's a
little grey Smurf Smurf it was one of
those at one point but Papa Smurf turned
her good and now Gargamel is like I'm
gonna turn Smurfette bad again and so
now we have the Smurfs - I appreciate
the elements in it Neil Patrick Harris
great Charlie from Heroes I know her as
Charlie from here I should know her as
her her actual name but I know her as
Charlie from heroes yeah I'm a
professional like that Brendan Gleeson
is in this movie he doesn't know why but
he's in there I even had a Papa Smurf
Pez when I was a kid so I'm like why
wouldn't I like this movie the answer is
simple and I will explain it to you I'm
gonna get this out of the way right off
the bat sadly it feels like everyone in
this movie is kind of phoning it in
because they all know that this movie's
made for kids so the like we can give
half-ass performances and they do
doesn't mean they're bad actors it just
means they know nothing was expected of
them and now they're here to get their
paycheck and this is just how it goes
so yeah the acting is not great the
writing is not great either Hank
Azaria's Gargamel's a guy where you're
like he's having the most fun with the
movie does it save the movie doesn't
make the movie get it does not die you
can tell it's like well if I'm phoning
it in I'm gonna have fun doing it there
are movies that are made for families
and that's different than movies that
are made for kids movies that are made
for family it's like adults can go to it
kids can go to it everyone's gonna have
a good time movies that are made for
kids adults pawn the kids off to a
babysitter and the babysitter takes them
to watch it you'd also like we dodged
that bullet this is that one so in that
I'm like it's a kids movie I am an adult
it's not made for me so maybe I should
take it a little easy on the movie but I
shouldn't and I can't and here's why
because the movie completely panders the
kids that the movie is made for and it
goes on the assumption that kids need
everything explained for them that's the
best way to go about making a kid's
movie that's not true this movie's so
in-your-face it leaves nothing to the
imagination kids don't have to use their
brain at all in the movie which sucks
this terrible
doing kids a disservice is making your
kids dumber when they watch it example
not really a spoiler it's kind of
whatever so Smurfs - are you really
concerned with spoilers this is just one
example off the top of my head right
here but there are a lot of others in
this movie the big thing in this movies
family and what's important and has a
parallel in there there are a couple of
different family issues happening in the
movie so um Papa Smurf from the Smurfs
go to save Smurfs at a smart movie would
be like when she's like oh you came for
me maybe Papa Smurf can like you know do
that thing the finger on the chin thing
where he's like of course and she's
maybe she looks up and has a tear and
they hug and you get the fact that the
important thing is family and they both
understood that in that moment and kids
will be like oh yeah oh family I get it
they had to use their brain for a second
to connect aid to be and be like wait
why did he okay family in this movie
Papa Smurf will be like of course
because we're a family and that's what
family does in which case it's explained
to kids what the thing is and so kids
don't have to use their brains it's just
explaining the entire movie to kids
that's what every take in this movie is
everything is just explained to kids
there's nothing that they have to use
their brains for if you don't spoon feed
the answers to kids in the movies and
you force them to go oh hey I need to
piece that together then they'll have to
do that and maybe they won't be sever
thing together because they're too young
but they'll watch the movie a few years
later and be like oh I didn't catch that
when I was younger now I caught that now
and it has replay value and relevance
and it holds the test of time this movie
has none of that they have all the
answers the first time they watched the
movie no matter what age they are it
bums me out I'm not saying kids need a
mental test when they watch a movie
there is less enjoyment in a movie when
everything is just given to you at face
value that's what the Smurfs 2 does
everything set surface value just simple
dialogue simple jokes like the movie was
written in Cranberry year old it's a
movie that you turn on when you have a
family get-together so you can just plug
the kids in and the adults can go smoke
cigars and drink brandy or wine get
trashed and just forget the fact that
their parents for a couple hours and
will it work yeah Wilfred like
two-year-old two-year-olds will lock
into this movie just fine and be like
I'm entertained because I'm 2 years old
and that's enough for me in fact if you
put this movie on to shut your kids up
for a couple hours and just entertain
them mindlessly and you have access to
any other kids movie around or Netflix
you have failed you have failed them
just pray to God none of them become
president there is a scene in this movie
that actually put this movie into
perspective for me here it is there's a
scene where Azrael the cat's just
perplexed with this laser
and someone's shining a little laser pen
he's trying to get the dot like cats do
but he can't just like Azrael the cat
kids will see this and they'll be
entertained because it's there it's just
there and it's entertaining them because
its motion on a screen there are much
better kids movies out there if people
have not completely [ __ ] on this movie
it's because of one scene in one scene
only in the scene is actually this might
be kind of a spoiler but are you really
concerned the scene is the baddies and
Gargamel are trying to get Smurfette you
know to kind of turn to the dark side
there's a scene where the Smurfs are on
the other side of this window and she
finally gets a little wand and she's
like yeah it's good be in bed she starts
shooting laser bolts and they're all
their hearts break the like oh no and
she blows out the window and all the
Smurfs blast backwards as the right
amount of heart the right amount of
emotion the right amount of slo-mo right
there I was like maybe this movie isn't
a complete piece of [ __ ] and the very
next scene the very next moment the
Smurfs haven't even hit the ground yet
they're still falling and now we hit
stick and [ __ ] humor and just
everything that makes the scene before
it crumble into insignificance and I was
like okay well that's done and over with
the emotional tone is now just gone I
just don't see why we need a Smurfs
movie that takes place in our world
where you have real actors that are good
actors forced to be shitty actors
phoning it in for a paycheck when you
can have the Smurfs in there Smurfs land
and Gargamel up in his castle and
Gargamel is trying to take out the
Smurfs and the Smurfs
you know they join together and they try
to take out the big life-sized [ __ ]
who's trying to just stop him out that
would be why can't you do that it'd be a
good animated family movie but not we
have this movie he gives nothing to
adults it gives nothing to kids I don't
know why I did you know why this movie
was made because the first one made half
a billion dollars worldwide that's why
we have this merge to this movie wasn't
entirely [ __ ] though it was smurfing
Smurfs [ __ ] so what is the worst family
movie that you've seen you know those
movies that are made for kids really
like that's just unwatchable whatever it
is comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you